policing Kinshasa pushed back opposition
leader Moise katumbi and his supporters
the crowds are trying to reach the
Electoral commission building in the
Congolese capital
from now on President Philip chisekeli
must know that we will be coming here
every Thursday to protest against what
they are doing with the elections
process until we have free and credible
elections in the country
protesters are demanding an
international audit of the entire
electoral Commission
to say no to the ongoing electoral
process which the current president is
trying to fix for himself and his people
we refuse this with all our energy this
is why we are protesting
president
feel in 2019 critics say since then he's
Consolidated his power by hand-picking
loyalists to run the Electoral
commission and accuse him of appointing
judges who are biased
Amnesty International and other rights
groups have also accused him of
declaring a state of Siege in the
eastern North kivu and ituri provinces
to crack down on descent these are areas
known to be opposition strongholds
what Felix and his people are doing is
unacceptable in a state which is
supposed to be a democracy people have
died in this country for Freedom we will
not accept a dictatorship now
governing party supporters dismiss such
protests as an attempt to discredit the
government elections are scheduled to
take place in December
thousands of opposition protesters say
they'll keep up the pressure to ensure a
fair process Victoria gate and B Al
Jazeera